elle s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est
vincent macaigne bonjour où jouent et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
comédiens vous êtes pascal molitor dans
le nouveau film de benoît délépine et
gustave kervern qui est sorti hier au
cinéma qui s'appelle en même temps
satire burlesque et grinçante de la
politique et de notre époque en garde
quelques images
gauche droite gauche droite way with one
l'apport elle va changer quand on sait
bien
il faut que vous compreniez que vous
voulez passer de bipèdes ou quadrupèdes
vous baissez votre faute devant un
portrait de neubourg un bel exemple si
mauvaise qu'on a un vidéo surveiller les
vaches en somme
si les journées en irak les antilles ans
est vraiment devenue intenable
[Applaudissements]
en fait c'est tout nouveau comme ça
ce conte de fées
c'est si on parlait plus des migrateurs
des migrants des campagnes électorales
mans pour y
moi je vais changer tu commences à me
faire de plus en plus toi
voilà vous êtes vincent macaigne dans ce
film un élu écologiste du genre rabat
joie et donneurs de leçons et vous vous
retrouvez donc coller littéralement
collé à votre corps défendant à jonathan
cohen qui lui joue un maire du genre
requins sans complexe homophobes et j'en
passe qui tentent de vous corrompre et
vous allez tenter au cours d'une nuit
est riche en péripéties de vaud décoller
vous regardez la bande-annonce et vous
riez encore ouais ça film qui est très
très très très drôle je pense enfin en
plus on a fait pas mal d'avant-premières
alors c'est ça fait du bien quand même
deux pouvant un peu rigoler que la
politique non et puis c'était aussi une
volonté je croix de gustave kervern et
de benoît delépine d'essayer d'aller
vite pressé de sortir le film un peu
avant les élections le fait que de tels
scénarios puisse exister et surtout
qu'ils deviennent des films ça rassurant
sur la santé du cinéma français ouais en
tout cas chez moi je trouve que c'est
important de pouvoir
faire des films qui ont une forme de
fantaisie qui se permettent de parler de
la politique en même temps d'en rigoler
ça fait beaucoup de bien moi je trouve
en ce moment
de voir ce film en fait casting
formidable notamment par votre présence
celle de jonathan cohen françois damiens
on l'a vu à l'instant qui répètent tous
deux fois et yolande moreau en mère
maquerelle à quoi ça correspond à quoi
ça ressemble un tournage de délépine et
kervern c'est comme leur film en fait
c'est complètement fou s'est il ya
beaucoup de fantaisie et beaucoup de
fous rires et ils savent faire une sorte
d'amour énorme pour les acteurs et pour
les situations bon le film il est
politisé mais en fait il est surtout
c'est surtout une vraie comédie c'est
assez hilarant et il essaie de trouver
le le gag et puis finalement ils sont
comme comme quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
rigolent ils sont très très joyeux et
font très peu de prise ce qui peut être
très étonnant aussi avec un soin pour
l'écriture à la fois verbale et visuelle
il ya un nombre de jeux de mots et de
punchlines absolument exceptionnel qui
donne envie du coup de revoir le film
plusieurs fois au cas où on en a loupé
et des plombs de cinéma assez dingue il
ya que pour faire un plan assez long où
on voit un comédien caché derrière un
poteau quoi ouais c'est génial où ils
ont des idées hallucinante et puis il y
eut en fait ils aiment et cd il aime
écrire des scènes cultes quam s'est donc
fait tout ce film je pense qu'il ya au
moins je sais pas 10 15 moments cultes
dans le film avec en effet françois
damiens qui la rend
meiway les gendarmes la con que je vois
là sur l'écran c'est des scènes
complètement hilarant tout d'un coup les
policiers soient hyper brillant espère
politisé
ça suffit à se suffire à elle-même en
réalité on a l'impression de parfois de
ouais c'est vrai c'est le sait aussi
leur univers de groland qu'ils ont
qu'ils apportent au cinéma mais c'est
vraiment dans la lignée de tout leur
fille soit mamoutou cet amour ils aiment
ça ils aiment que chaque lancement une
sorte d' inventions avec presque un gag
et dans chaque dans chaque séquence non
mais j'ai adoré ton avec eux jean n'a eu
des fous rires hallucinant avec jonathan
qui est lui-même assez hilarant quoi est
il ya un propos bien sûr dans ce film
vous le disiez benoît délépine et du
staff garden ont voulu faire un film non
pas tant sur le candidat auquel le titre
du film fait penser mais sur ce qui est
devenu la politique au fil du temps une
espèce de propension à vouloir contenter
tout le monde qui mène à des exercices
d'équilibriste le personnage que vous
incarnez on est l'illustration oui c'est
vrai et aussi je pense qu'ils ont voulu
face à un film sur le vivre ensemble
quoi ça que l'on retrouve deux de demers
en fait coller à l'un à l'autre ils vont
être obligés
avec de la colle avec de la colle et
vont être obligés bas de se côtoyer et
de d'apprendre l'un d'eux l'un de
l'autre en fait et c'est une sorte de
métaphore afin de la france et ça les
faisait rigoler de d'essayer de de
coller comme ça deux hommes politiques
complètement opposées et puis est ce
chemin là quoi deux des hommes
politiques à saran pas vraiment ses
lettres de noblesse à la politique en
revanche ça ouvre la voie à la
possibilité d'une forme de rédemption
ouais ouais je pense qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'espoir et croit vachement
c'est aussi un film qui est très
généreux et qui était qui fait qu'ils
ont un énorme respect des mères en fait
de tous ces maires de toutes les villes
de province
ou qui font un boulot hallucinant il ya
une phrase dans le film que je trouve
assez belle où mon personnage du bab et
où il y aura plus personne pour
provôté merapi non plus par personne
pour qui voter quoi donc ils ont une
sorte de respect énorme des hommes
politiques et des mers et c'est
extrêmement drôle et extrêmement bête ce
quoi souvent mais il a une forme d'amour
et de respect d'espoir de ses
personnages avec une satire de tout ce
qui fait à peu près notre époque les
thèmes de la campagne électorale la
réelle pour le coût actuel tout le monde
en prend plus ou moins pour son grade 2
dans tout le champ politique qui
existent y compris et là pour le coup
c'est il ya les deux versants de la
pièce sur les sur les féministes donc
avec ce groupe qui s'appelle les
call-girls cole co2 l es qui
s'embrouille avec leur écriture
inclusive enfin la parole inclusive
cette scène aussi assez génial c'est à
la fois ça et en même temps un hommage
aussi à ceux à ce mouvement
dont on dit parfois qu'il est trop
radical je sais pas ce que je crois
qu'ils aiment beaucoup ça ils sont très
proches de plasne féministe enfin ils
ont aimé chemin ici je crois qu'ils sont
quand même plus tôt ils font plutôt le
film pour les coureurs et disons qu'ils
s'en moquent avec tendresse voilà voilà
voilà il ya vachement non pas par contre
c'est là qu'il ya beaucoup de tendresse
et puis chaque personnage a des versants
bon et déversant un peu plus
caricaturaux et idiot quoi mais c'est
vraiment tout leur univers en fait il se
moque de toutes les tares après je pense
qu'ils ont un
ils font le film bruce a filmé
jose padilla plein de mots
je sais pas ouais en tout cas ça film
que je pense qu'ils font parce qu'il
s'inquiète des menaces écologiques et
puis et ils s'inquiètent aussi et
surtout
enfin ils sont pour le féminisme non
j'essaie un peu de raconter ça sent trop
voilà c'est kafkaïen passionné c'est le
on essaie de ne pas manger trop de temps
de parole dans ce contexte de campagne
électorale il sait en france en tout cas
le film ça c'est une certitude et on
peut le dire est sorti quatre jours
avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle et ça évidemment c'est
par hasard ils se sont dépêchés pour
qu'il sorte précise ultra dépêché d'une
manière un peu naïve enfin jeu
évidemment que ça fera rien changé aux
élections mais c'est aussi une manière
de divertir tout le monde et puis de
rajouter leur petite pierre je pense à
ce moment politique
donc oui ce sont des péchés pour la
tournée en décembre et donc ils ont fait
le montage d'une manière extrêmement
rapide pour vraiment le sortir avant le
avant les élections c'était vraiment
leur volonté quoi pas sûr que
effectivement ils permettent à ceux qui
regardent le film de se sentir plus
serein sur l'élection comment vous
expliquez vous sans rentrer dans le
détail des parties des uns et des autres
mais qu'à 4 jours 3 jours de l'élection
les français soient aussi perdu
en tout cas le film ne raconte pas ce
que on rigole avec ça mais en fait il ya
quelque chose où il ya trop de choses en
même temps m dos d'où le titre en fait à
mon avis il ya il ya des questions très
grave à résoudre on est abreuvé toute la
journée de questions très grave le film
en parle aussi d'ailleurs et c'est des
questions tellement grave que tout le
monde doit s'y atteler quoi et c'est pas
forcément ça ne regarde pas forcément un
parti politique est à mon avis ces deux
êtres qui sont collés se rendre compte
des problèmes plus graves que et qu'en
fait au dessus de leurs ou de leurs
arrivisme ou de leurs idées politiques
il ya un monde et on est dans un moment
historique où on doit tous se réunir
quand même bon alors c'est parce que ça
n'arrive pas mais on doit réussir à se
réunir à se coller les uns aux autres
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
qui vont nous aider à améliorer le monde
rô le monde on vit quoi donc c'est des
choses très bête et très naïve et je
pense que gustave kervern et
benoît delépine seller leurs propos en
fait c'est qu'il ya des choses qui sont
au dessus de nous et que ça vaut pas la
peine de trop se quereller mais qu'il
faut qu'on se mette ensemble parce qu'on
a des vrais problèmes en commun à
résoudre quoi d'ailleurs il ya une scène
qui a un qui est un quasi prophétique
assez dingue où les deux personnages
sont devant une station essence music le
film a été tourné au mois de décembre
oui et on voit les prix l'essence qui
qui monte à une folle jusqu'à arriver au
prix actuel ouais causées par la guerre
en ukraine une question pour finir sur
vous vincent macaigne on vous a vu vous
étiez là d'ailleurs pour nous en parler
l'année dernière avec le très sombre
médecin nuit la comédie pour le coup
assez grinçante dans quelques semaines
adaptation de la nouvelle série de la
nouvelle série d'olivier assayas qui est
une adaptation de son film de 96 irma
ouais parce que c'est comme ça que vous
voyez votre métier de comédien faut
changer tout le temps de registre abbas
est jamais s'ennuyer entre que c'est
extrêmement agréable de pouvoir tourner
dans un film de gus afkar khaled et
lépine et de fer à cheval clivage man et
de se transformer que ce soit
physiquement
brolin dans le film j'ai un énorme
bouquet de faire des films drôles ou
très sombre c'est
c'est un énorme bonheur quoi mais c'est
ça oui c'est sûr que c'est comme ça que
je vois les choses je serai très ennuyé
de faire toujours le même film assez
diffusion au mois de juin c'est ça le
drame avait pu normalement autour de
d'alicia avis candeur comédienne
suédoise oscarisé quel casting encore
merci beaucoup vincent macaigne
commercial reviendra pour parler d'un
autre registre de films du coup
peut-être bonne journée oui merci bonne
journée